well the national teacher of the year is
one of ccsd's own julianna urtube got
quite the surprise
very early this morning we shared the
announcement live on good day las vegas
bianca holman starts off our team
coverage she shows us how it all played
out
a dramatic reveal on cbs this morning
led into uplifting news for the silver
state
and our city and the 2021 national
teacher of the year drum roll pleased
tony and anthony
juliana ortave of las vegas
urtube is a special education teacher
like all educators this year she worked
hard to ensure no child fell through the
cracks
first lady dr jill biden walked into
kermit booker elementary school library
surprising the teacher of the year with
flowers ertvae says dr biden is one of
her heroes and it was a shock to meet
her and hear words of
gratitude from her students cbs this
morning anchor tony decouple asked ira
bay what teachers need
teaching is hard to work you know it's a
work of the heart and
it's about connecting and making
relationships i'm advocating for
students to have a joyous and just
education this dedicated educator is
known as miss
earth using a garden to give her
students hands-on experiences and
lessons that reflect their culture
for many of her students english is a
second language
since urdu bay is bilingual she goes
beyond what is required
bonding with her spanish-speaking
families on good day las vegas she
shared the impact of the pandemic
this year has really just made us
realize how important it is
to maintain our connections to each
other this is a team
we absolutely have to work together with
families and partner with them and
the students and just keep focused on
what is truly important
which is our students being well and
safe and taken care of
as the first teacher of the year from
nevada to be recognized as the national
teacher of the year
erda bay will use this upcoming year
serving as an advocate for all teachers
bianca holman 8 news now
after the big reveal ccsd leaders and
state representatives gathered to honor
miss utterbay
with a local celebration hector mejia
was there
and he continues our team coverage
hey there and here's how monumental this
is for nevada governor steve sisolak u.s
senator jackie rosen
and congresswoman suzy lee came down to
personally congratulate
our very own national teacher of the
year so let's go back to earlier this
morning
tom clark county school district leaders
were down here too for the celebration
juliana ortube is the first educator in
nevada to be named
national teacher of the year huge
recognition
she teaches special education in grades
pre-k through fifth at booker elementary
here
in the historic west side neighborhood
an underserved part of the valley
hertube served on the superintendent's
supervisory committee during the course
of the pandemic
she met with the state superintendent
weekly being a voice for her own
students
she's now in the national spotlight not
only representing ccsd
but all teachers across america families
shouldn't have to fight
for a joyous and just school they
shouldn't have to fight for a school
that will help
that child maintain their identities
that will celebrate them as their family
as a family unit and so that's why i
work so hard to make sure that families
know that they're welcome
that we love them that we're so excited
to share their school and that we
acknowledge their child as their biggest
sacrifice their biggest joy and so to
hand that over to us
we have to treat it children with care
superintendent dr jesus jarrah said
she's an example of the american dream
her two-based family immigrated to the
u.s from colombia
when she was just a child and during the
presentation you could just really see a
twinkle in her eye
when everyone talked about her and they
thanked her she mentioned she would love
to have a parade down las vegas
boulevard but right now
some properties along the strip have
agreed to put her picture up on display
after four o'clock this afternoon
reporting outside booker elementary
hector mejia
8 news now